en directo a América es hora de hablar
de economía y por ello me acompañan el
estudio mi compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge
bienvenido es una nueva semana un nuevo
día pero nosotros tenemos que seguir
hablando de las turbulencias bancarias
en Estados Unidos y es que solamente en
la jornada de hoy las acciones de First
Republic Bank cayeron hasta un 47% esto
luego del que la calificadora de riesgo
de samp global volviera a rebajar su
calificación crediticia por segunda vez
en una semana esto pese al posible
rescate que parecía ser poco para
tranquilizar a los inversores ya que el
precio de sus acciones siguió cayendo
hasta terminar en 12,18 dólares por
acción la acción ya perdido un 90%
solamente este año es anti global dijo
que el rescate de 30 mil millones de
dólares por parte de alguno de los
mayores bancos de Wall Street podrían no
resolver los retos sustanciales Aunque
de alguna forma va a aliviar la presión
de liquidez al corto plazo el banco está
en conversaciones para obtener capital
de otros bancos o empresas de capital de
riesgo mediante la emisión de nuevas
acciones y también podría negociar un
acuerdo para su venta Bueno y este fin
de semana lluvias compró a su rival
Credit suiz por 3200 millones de dólares
bueno Esto con el principal objetivo de
evitar un contagio o una nueva crisis
financiera global las autoridades suizas
empujaron a lluvias a comprar a su rival
después de que el precio de las acciones
de crédito se desplomara y los
depositantes huyeran Credit suites No es
cualquier banco a diferencia de silicon
que quebró a principios de este mes en
Estados Unidos este banco es uno de los
30 bancos clasificados como de
importancia mundial porque supone
mayores problemas si llega a quebrar
Aunque la confianza en los bancos es
débil los economistas los reguladores
bancarios y también los analistas
bursátiles afirman que los bancos están
en mejor forma que en 2008 durante la
crisis financiera global con unos
colchones financieros más sólidos frente
a las pérdidas y también nuevas
normativas la pregunta ahora es si esta
movida logrará calmar a los temores para
muchos analistas la contención de esta
crisis es como una especie de lotería
mientras se apagan los fuegos otros
pueden surgir bueno y seguimos con
rondas de despidos porque Amazon anunció
el recorte de otros nueve mil puestos
bueno con esto Amazon recortaría
aproximadamente
27.000 empleos en los últimos meses en
total estos despidos se tratan del mayor
de todas las tecnológicas en términos
absolutos Aunque si se comparen cifras
relativas es menos del 2% del total de
sus empleados la empresa emplea a unos
1,5 millones de trabajadores el sector
tecnológico lidera los despidos en
Estados Unidos en los últimos meses se
han recortado más de 200,000 puestos en
varias empresas es el repunte que
tuvieron durante la pandemia al pasar
los confinamientos cayó la demanda de
algunos productos y servicios de las
tecnológicas y esto sumado a que la
economía global se desacelera por la
subida de los tipos de interés que hace
que las empresas recorten personal en
grandes cantidades de todas las
tecnológicas la única que aún esquiva
despidos masivos es Apple Bueno ya
veremos qué panorama continúa vamos
ahora Panamá porque concluyó la asamblea
del banco interamericano de desarrollo
bueno el banco anunció que busca ampliar
entre sus objetivos su brazo de
inversión privada y antes de la asamblea
también se celebraron seis seminarios
técnicos en los que expertos debatieron
sobre temas como la reducción de la
pobreza la desigualdad la biodiversidad
y el crecimiento sostenible en su último
informe el organismo detalló que prevé
un crecimiento para la región del 1%,
una baja significativa tomando en cuenta
el tomando en cuenta el 3,9% que se
registró en 2022 el bit dice que la
región sufrirá los efectos de un menor
crecimiento mundial tasas de interés en
niveles de deuda muy altos durante el
encuentro también se habló de la
situación bancaria global ahí nuestro
corresponsal en Panamá Oscar zurbarán
conversó con el ministro de hacienda de
chile sobre el impacto inmediato de la
crisis en el sector Financiero en su
país
en el caso de chile el impacto
que más ha sentido tiene que ver con la
calidad de los precios de las materias
primas incluyendo el cobre eso ha
contribuido de evaluar en el margen
nuestra moneda respecto del dólar pero
el sistema financiero chileno en
relación a las antiguas situaciones que
hemos visto es considerablemente más
sólido Dado que los requerimientos de
capital de basilea tres ya están en
aplicación en Chile desde hace tres o
cuatro años atrás y se aplican a todas
las instituciones financieras de modo
que
los temas más bien tienen que ver con el
impacto indirecto que esto puede tener
que no tiene por qué ser menor puede ser
significativo como ha sido en otras
oportunidades Jorge cerramos este
espacio con la cifra del día la cifra es
2900 millones de dólares Ese es el
rescate del directorio del fondo
monetario internacional para Siri lancas
sri lanka dejó de pagar su deuda externa
en abril del 2022 mientras se sumía en
una peor crisis económica quedándose sin
efectivo para financiar incluso las
importaciones esenciales y provocando
por supuesto un enorme descontento
social Muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica lo invito a que se
quede con nosotros que ya Seguimos aquí
en directo a América con directo a
[Música]